le cri de ralliement de ces soldats de
l'US Navy résonne dans la capitale
américaine comme des encouragements pour
ses combattantes ukrainiennes qui ont
momentanément quitté le front elles ont
5 jours pour convaincre des décideurs
américains de leur donner plus d'armes
car celles déjà reçue en fait toute la
différence lors de la dernière
contre-offensive
quand les lance-missiles highmar sont
apparues sur le champ de bataille ils
ont durement frappé les positions russes
jusqu'à atteindre et détruire leur dépôt
de munitions
Ivana médecin de famille converti en
médecin chef d'un bataillon est venu
témoigner des exactions russes qu'elle a
pu voir de ses propres yeux
de crimes de guerre le plus horrible
pour elle c'est de voir des enfants
victimes d'armes interdites ils
utilisent des bombes à fragmentation et
des bombes au phosphore
Adriana recta au Père des chars d'assaut
c'est une spécialiste du déminage depuis
l'annexion de la Crimée en 2014 et la
libérer pas moins de cette ville
et nous rencontrons pour la première
fois en personne Yarina
aide-soignante opératrice de drone de
reconnaissance elle nous avait donné
quelques entrevues depuis le front du
Dombasle
nous avons besoin de char car l'Ukraine
est occupé par des chars et elle doit
être libérée par des chars
la récente mobilisation partielle
décrétée par Vladimir Poutine n’inquiète
pas ses combattantes outre mesure
ce geste trahit le désespoir de Poutine
c'est une grande force
n'ont aucune motivation parce qu'ils ne
défendent pas leur pays
elles sont arrivées avec une liste
détaillée de leurs besoins militaires
fournis par leur commandement ce
qu'elles veulent c'est le plus découvrir
de charniers
car même si le mot génocide semble
difficile à admettre ailleurs en Ukraine
c'est la malheureuse réalité
ce n'est pas juste de l'armement mais il
s'agit de protéger des vies et de leur
permettre de survivre à l'hiver notre
artillerie est faible devant celle des
Russes le potentiel de guerre de la
Russie est vraiment énorme
15 minutes c'est le temps dont il
dispose pour convaincre chaque sénateur
qu'elles vont rencontrer le séjour est
organisé par l'intenation n'aurait pas
briqué n Institute qui en est à sa
sixième mission de lobbying en faveur de
l'Ukraine un institut proche du parti
républicain et financé par le
gouvernement
fédérald
[Musique]
les retours sont encourageants avec un
large soutien bipartisan pour plus
d'assistance à l'Ukraine ces dames
fournissent des informations à jour
dit-il elles sont des témoins directs de
ce qui se passe
des décideurs à l'écoute mais qui
doivent eux-mêmes tenir compte de
l'opinion de leurs électeurs
obtenir la paix et la sécurité en
s'armant davantage
envers son président et la communauté
internationale de ne pas avoir accepté
des négociations impossibles avec la
Russie weekend
il faut les sortir par la force et non
avec des accords de paix les
négociations ne seront possibles que si
la Russie devenait une démocratie
déterminée prête à défendre leur nation
jusqu'au bout
après la victoire